so you ever wonder why certain leaders
get the best out of their people and
some leaders don't
you ever wonder why certain people love
working for their boss or their leader
or their men whoever it is
man i don't know why they want to run
through the wall for him or her
why is it that they do so many different
why are they dying to be on that
person's team
but how come they don't do it for me i
want people to treat me better
i want people to be loyal to me why does
he have loyalty i can't find loyal
people
i hear this all the time let me unpack
this entire concept for you
and hopefully this will make sense to
you so think about it this way in a week
you have 168 hours
in a week right 160 that's 24 times 768
hours in a week
say you sleep eight hours a night times
seven that's 56 hours
that leaves us around 110 hours in a
week out of that 110 hours a week
think about what portion of that 110
hours is spent waking up
going to work lunch drive how many hours
is that can we say 55 60 hours
let's say 60 hours is spent waking up in
the morning you're not around family you
wake up toothbrush shower
shave car prepare clothes drive get
there at work you go lunch with your
peers you come home drive
so say 60 hours a week you're working
preparing all that stuff
50 hours a week is left here for family
out of that 50 hours a week say 10 hours
is running errands you're going around
doing certain things
then some of the times you're watching
tv and then it's actual time
with your family right what does this
mat tell you
that the average person spends more time
with the people they
work with than their own family which
means your work
team environment becomes your second
family now some people may say
well that's a shame that people spend
more time with their family than
with their co-workers and their own
family uh no
if a person spends more time with their
family than the people they work with
they're probably broke i just want you
to know this the kids are probably not
in the best place financially
this is why we go to work to be able to
provide for the people we love the most
so now let's look at this families who
have kids
that are loyal to their parents and
leaders
who have co-workers or team members that
are loyal to them what do they have in
common here's what it is
i watch a lot of people when they have
certain people that work for them
they see them as he's my worker like you
own them type of a deal
nobody's ever going to stay with you
long term if you look at a person that's
my worker
no one likes to work for somebody like
that they don't
no kid wants the parent to kind of be
like well
you know it's because of me that they
did this kid wants to have their own
identity
to be loyal to their family right a
loving type of an environment how do you
create a deeper relationship with
certain people you work with here's what
it is
the people that i've seen over the years
who get
loyal people that run through the wall
for them
and eventually they have a core group of
people that want to be in business with
them for
years after year after year for years to
come
here's what they do while the average
leader only takes a relationship one
layer deep or maybe two
the one that earns loyalty goes one two
three
four five six layers deeper the one that
goes six layers deeper eventually wins
loyalty
the one that goes to doesn't win loyalty
so let's unpack this what it means so
i read a book once called thank god it's
monday it's written by psychologist a
marriage therapist that talks about
thank god it's monday most husbands
cannot wait for his money to be away
from family oh my gosh it's so
problematic
i want to go to work i'm sick and tired
of being around family crying screaming
out
arguing my wife i want to go to work
right
he said after 20 years of being a
psychologist and i watch which marriages
work the best the ones that work the
best is
the husband gave undivided attention to
the wife
where she was able to talk to him and
say here's what my day looked like and
both of them got the
dosage of it the parents who got the
best out of their kids
each night each kid got undivided
attention a five-minute call
a five-minute conversation like so how
was your day what were you doing what
happened to the really
what happened today with oh no what's
mary doing how's bobby doing undivided
attention right one
on one is the highest level of quality
relationships you build where you build
loyalty
one on one the bigger the group setting
it is the easier it is
on you but the layer of loyalty goes
lower and lower and lower
the more one-on-one it is smaller group
at his loyalty goes higher so that's
family now let's bring that to business
so if a boss works like this hey john
how you doing
great did you get your job done
phenomenal great
have a wonderful day now if i've never
met the wife
if i've never met the husband if there's
not an environment where i get to know
my
direct at least direct reports i want to
know the family
i want to know who the kids are i want
to know what your goals are i want to
know what your dreams are
i want to take you out to lunch i want
to go to coffee i want to spend some
time with you
one on one the more the layers go deeper
and deeper
and deeper and deeper and deeper the
more relationships you build the more
it's
transactional people feel it you can't
just fake it by the way people know when
it's transactional when it's just like
like this and the more sincere it is and
by the way some people are watching say
well pat i do everything right and i
still can't find loyal people
well maybe you haven't done it long
enough and maybe you got to give a
little bit more time because it took me
a couple years as well until i find a
loyal people myself that have been with
me
for decades now 15 years how come
they're not leaving because
i understood they matter more than i
matter
the priority has to be with them i have
to understand what's important to these
guys
i got a call yesterday from one of my
guys that they're having a challenge
with
they're working with a certain client of
theirs that's in new york how do we deal
with this new york client
do you know them do you know the spouse
do you know the kid do you know this i
don't
why don't you go to relationship first
then go to selling then go to all that
other stuff
first comes trust then comes loyalty
first come trust
then come speed first you gain my trust
then you can challenge me
first you gain my trust then you can
give me advice but you got to figure
out a way to earn my trust for me to say
this guy cares about me this is somebody
i want to be in business with for very
very long time
so if you're watching this i got a
challenge for you if you're watching
this you're saying well pat
how do i test this out for myself make a
list of the people that are the most
loyal to you
ask yourself how many layers deep of a
relationship have you built with them
make it a list of the people that you
value the most what haven't you done
with them
and what do you need to start doing
today to make that relationship deeper
and deeper and deeper
do you need to put a barbecue at your
house and invite them over do you need
to say well can i take you out and my
wife and
your wife and the four of us go out to
dinner together can you do something
with the kids to have a you know
getaway and they're just kind of having
a party to get out the house by the pool
and hanging out or going to a park
together with the kids their kids and
your kids
and building a relationship together the
stronger these bonds get
you remember in birthdays anniversaries
the stronger these bonds get
eventually going to look around and say
my gosh
we got a big group of loyal people and
your leaders start treating their
teammates and their direct reports
the same way you did to them now you got
a strong team that's willing to run
through the wall for everybody together
and the vision is becoming a reality so
if you watch this video there was
value for you with watching this video i
got another video i want you to watch
i made this video a few years back on
how to create a kind of a company
culture where people want to be a part
of us 20
24 different points on how to create a
kind of a company culture where people
want to be a part of
it's if you're not watching it's very
thorough very detailed
click over here to watch this video and
they give you how to create a stronger
company culture at where you're working
at
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so have a great week
everybody take care bye
[Music]